couple of months ago I was asked to
deliver the commencement speech for
Berkeley's December graduation I was
like great I love Berkeley I'm off in
December and it'll be a sentimental
journey who doesn't remember their
graduation in December but whatever I'm
happy to do it because though I never
attended Berkeley I was very aware of
their place in the American debate on
the far left in a country where the
Democratic Party is sold out to the
center and even the right this is what
is needed this is why I wanted to accept
this invitation and they invited me
because it was the 50th anniversary of
something that is legendary on that
campus the Berkeley Free Speech Movement
I guess they don't teach irony in
college anymore and then a few weeks ago
Ben Affleck was on our show and we had a
discussion about Islam that I've had a
thousand one night with a lot of other
people but he's an a-list movie star so
now our very deep media started to care
about it
it's always easy to do a story about
somebody being mad at somebody so when a
few thousand people online who didn't
have to do anything more than click a
button who didn't even go to Berkeley
necessarily wanted to be me to be
disinvited as the commencement speaker
because you know I'm a racist right
because Islam is a race you know this is
the level of logic we're dealing with by
the way even reza aslan my most strident
critic has gone to pains to say he
doesn't think I'm a bigot here's what he
said on HuffPost live he said Bill Maher
is not a bigot I know him
we are friends we hang out with each
other backstage he loves having me on
the show despite the fact that he
disagrees with me on a lot of things and
that shows the kind of person that he is
if even my most respectable critic who's
a Muslim says this what leg does this
protest have to stand on he and I
disagree on some stuff but he's always
welcome on this show that's how it's
done kids who ever
who ever told you you only had to hear
what didn't upset you so anyway the
university has come down on my side
saying what I hope they would say all
along which is that were liberals we're
supposed to like free speech so I want
to come I'm planning to come
I'm planning a trip to the redwoods the
next day my only reservation and not
coming is the argument that it will be a
media circus and turn what should be a
day about the graduates which it should
be you into something else I don't want
to do that it's the only reason I would
ever pull out but let me say this to
those students worried about that I
promise this will be your day this is a
commencement speech the issue is you my
speech was is I hope gonna be about you
and whatever tips that I thought could I
actually help you in life because I
already lived through it that in my hunk
about how Jewish women hate to have sex
so here's my final plea to you liberal
in the truest sense of the word college
students not just in Berkeley but all
over the country please weigh in on this
my reputation isn't on the line yours is